The joe rogan experience.
It's one of most common traits,
much humans,
man,
I have a really tough time and there are some really cool people down here,
but I have a lot of trouble with LMN.
You should.
San Cisco is superior.
Well,
I think everybody in San Francisco has Asperger's,
so they'd just say what's on their mind,
whether it's appropriate or not.
So,
which is is really refreshing but can be frustrating.
But the converse in la,
man,
it's like Jesus,
like how many layers to this onion of a person to have to peel back to know what
the fuck you're actually trying to say to me.
Yes,
that is a huge issue.
And it's an issue because of the entertainment industry.
The entertainment industry fosters bullshit because you have to pretend to be
something a unique and different.
And meanwhile you're just another fucking person who's going to pretend to be a
killer in a movie or pretend to be a princess or pretend to be at.
You're pretending you're faking it.
So like you to be the best at it,
you have to be fake.
You have to be a big fake person.
Good at lying.
It's really bananas.
And not only that,
you start to embody this.
Look,
look,
here's a perfect example.
Sean Penn is a brilliant actor.
He's very good at that.
Most likely because Sean Penn is fucking crazy.
Okay?
And Chris Rock was hosting the Academy Awards once and he was making fun of Jude
law about how Jude law's and everything.
What have we got?
Damn.
Can I see move without Jude luck?
It was pretty funny.
It was just joking.
It's a subject because Jude law is very prolific and he's excellent.
So He's used it a lot of movies.
So fucking Sean Penn takes the microphone afterwards and says,
Jude loves and all these movies because he's an amazing actor.
I'm like,
okay,
I want to beat you to death.
I want to beat you to death for,
for getting literal about a fucking Chris rock joke about a prolific actor.
Jesus Christ.
You fucking pretentious cock sucker.
Did you really say that you have friends at all?
Do you have anybody that busts your balls?
Do you know?
They take himself so God damn seriously and there were donkeys plus award show
wherever.
Where's I'll monkey suit.
You were,
oh,
we're all gonna agree to wear the same stupid outfit that we never were for
being comfortable in real.
Yeah.
Why don't you put a bow tie on?
You can't put me there with a white shirt and oh,
buttoned up jacket.
Are you guys rich?
Can you address any way the fuck you want?
Why is everybody dressing the same?
Oh,
were elegant this evening.
Why?
We have traditional attire on,
I just want to say that Jude Law's an amazing actor.
Yes.
Here,
here.
Let's go back to being pretentious to Chris rock actually exposed some reality.
Did he make fun of something?
No,
we have no room for that here.
We're helping the world,
but providing the arts.
You fucking Twat.
I want to punch you right in your stupid face.
He plays but like tough guys and movies.
We fucking like,
this movie is pretty good.
It plays a Mickey Cohen and this,
uh,
this new gangster squad movie fun movie.
It looks like Horse Shit.
Sean Penn's very good at that,
but most likely he's good at that because he's fucking crazy.
Which is why you had to explain a joke during the Academy Awards.
What a fucking brilliant world renounced standup comedian as the host of the
award.
Holy Shit to do a comedian make a joke.
Oh No,
stop.
Let me explain what's great you're making here.
I think in the same academy awards it was when Chris Rock was talking about 50
cent and said this guy's had dealt with everything.
He took more gunshots to the face than Jenna Jamison and they were both in the
audience.
Nobody got up and defended Jenna Jamison.
I was very offended.
You're allowed.
You're allowed to say that.
Yeah,
you're allowed to say that,
but that's a free target.
I make fun of Jude Law Cause he's a brilliant actor.
So she's butchered laws in a lot of films cause he's a brilliant doctor.
I just wanted to say,
I just want her to straighten everybody out.
I wanted to exercise my ego about some shit that happened earlier that I thought
was unjust.
Are you making fun of June law during our special day when we were a monkey?
Suits.
Fuck choke you like this one hand.
Are you going to,
Oh,
you'd do the scent of a woman like ranger choke on the boy.
I wouldn't even use my elbow.
I wouldn't even have to just grab him like a dove rocky like a little rant.
Hold on tight
shut.
It just pretentiousness is really intolerable and it shouldn't be tolerated in
your friends and it shouldn't be tolerated in celebrities either.
That's nonsense.
That kind of stuff is nonsense.
You're talking about acting cunt face.
Okay.
You're not saving the world.
You're not time traveling.
You didn't invent a nuclear weapon.
Okay.
You not needing to develop faster and enter in and either it's not like you came
up with five g,
you pretended to be a gangster and a movie and you were good at it.
Thank you.
Thanks for it.
Did entertain the main distracting me for an hour and a half cause that's all
the fuck you did.
Okay.
You,
you made me sit down and I enjoyed your performance and it made me not think
about my life and I got some thrills out of it.
It was very exciting and enjoyable to follow along.
That's all you did.
Okay.
He didn't fucking change the world.
You're not awesome.
You're guy who's good at pretending.
Fuckheads drives me nuts.
It drives me nuts and that is the one thing that I hate about this town and you
know,
and being a person who lives in two very real worlds,
the world of fighting in the world of standup comedy,
being a cage fighting commentator,
I see the realist of the real shit.
Human character exposed,
people cracking under pressure.
People rise to the occasion.
I see the realist of the real shit.
And then comedy,
nobody laughs,
you're not funny.
Okay.
If your point doesn't work,
they don't accept it into their mind.
It has to really work and you have to be in that moment.
You can't think about something that's completely opposite and say something
funny and have it be funny cause he won't work.
There's something weird going on.
It's not just the words coming out of your mouth,
it's you thinking about those words as they come out of your mouth and people
recognizing that you're in the moment,
which makes it funny.
Those are two very real things.
So when I see someone like pretentious and someone who just,
someone who's like taking themselves way too fucking seriously or wants a lot of
accolades and respect to something that's basically just,
that's what you're,
that's what you,
man,
you're really good at that.
This guy's really good at fixing people's eyes.
This guy's really good at driving cars.
You don't be an asshole.
It's really simple.
Don't take yourself too fucking seriously,
cause you don't deserve any extra appreciation.
You don't deserve any extra respect.
You don't deserve any extra attention.
You deserve exactly what the fuck you've already gotten.
And you should be super duper thankful for that.
And anytime you want more than what you're getting,
you're a cunt.
It's that simple.
If you demand respect,
you're a,
you're a cunt.
You're simply a cunt.
It's your problem.
You're you're imbalanced and need to take a yoga class.
You need to go on a mushroom trip,
go to Peru,
take some Iowasca,
do something,
but stop.
It's 2000 and fucking 13 we have no time for you anymore.
I have no time.
This,
there are so many flooded.
It's rats,
rats,
and a fucking sewer.
Goddammit.
[inaudible].